how often do you suffer from confusion
forgetfulness and a lack of focus and
mental Clarity well you could be one of
the six in ten people six in ten people
in Britain are now suffering from brain
fog on a daily basis since the covid
pandemic let's get more on that with our
resident GP Dr David Lloyd hello Doc
it's always great to see you thanks for
joining us this seems to be a thing
yes it is it wasn't actually invented
during covert the name started to appear
about 2020 but yes an awful lot more
people have seem to have it and it
encompasses as you so rightly say a lot
of different symptoms from forgetfulness
poor concentration word finding
difficulty word finding nothing I find
my favorite word of course is an hedonia
which is a lack of enjoying things so
it's a lot of different things and it
and luckily again because of this
horrible Disease an awful lot of
research has been done into it so we now
do have a medical model a scientific
model if you like for the damage that's
been done by covid which causes these
Neuropsychiatric symptoms I'm sure most
of us who've had covered will remember
that profound loss of taste and smell
well that's actually a Neuropsychiatric
symptom and has been the clue to trying
to understand what's going on in
people's brains
how can how does a brain fog impact on
people's daily lives
well it's an increasingly uh common
condition I see in in general practice
people are coming to me and they're
using that term very specifically uh and
I find myself putting it on medical
certificates and things now as well so I
think it's I think it's a very useful
term to help people understand some of
the things that they're going through
um both internal and external it's not
just covered it is also the immense
pressures that people are feeling under
at the moment and it's part of the sort
of symptom complex of coping with such a
stressful life yeah can you imagine
um having um had had covered and also
going through the menopause the level of
brain fog you have then anyway that's
that's another topic doctor for another
day
um
how can we reverse the impact of brain
fog what can we do
well they're just sticking on the Sands
where we think that there are uh new
treatments are going to come along which
which will be very useful there are
actual Medical Treatments which will
tackle the microglial cells in your
brain so we hope that there'll be some
things there but just like everything
else it is about is it is about
exercising your brain just like you'd
exercise your body so we know things
like cognitive behavior therapy uh is
very effective in this condition and
that is readily available in the NHS so
please uh if you're ever at all worried
and you've got this condition call your
GP he can put you in contact with your
local uh psychological therapy team and
it's a very effective treatment
um we um try to speak to you last week
um doc but you were too busy looking
after sick people quite rightly so uh so
can I just ask you quickly about what
we're going to ask you about last week
and that is the contraceptive pill and
whether it uh how concerned we should be
about it increasing the likelihood of
breast cancer
so it's my understanding that this is a
very very small risk and you've got to
balance that out against all the other
benefits of being on oral contraceptives
one of the things that isn't mentioned
very much for instance is that our
contraceptive pill protects you against
another evil cancer we can all feel all
all women can feel lumps in their
breasts at an early stage and get
effective treatment but ovarian cancer
is a quiet silent killer and the pill uh
absolutely reduces your risk massively
of that much more difficult disease so
we've known for some time there is a
small small risk and it is a very very
small risk and uh it but the the
advantages of oral contraception hugely
outweigh them so I pleased that if
there's anybody out there thinking of
stopping the pill because of this
increased Risk please don't because it's
uh it really is the most effective form
of contraception and the most effective
way of staying healthy as a woman when
into your your late middle age okay for
now Doc it's always a pleasure thank you
thank you